so brian having gone through that what
would you tell another filmmaker who
had their hopes up they really felt
passionate about a project money was on
the table things were really going well
and then it's it's totally yanked from
underneath them like how would you talk
about not just moving on but rebuilding
themselves well i don't think i mean i
don't think my experience is unique i
think a lot of people go through that
um but being a young filmmaker out of
sundance and getting you know getting
this attention and then
you know i would say that
um
to realize that it's a it's a career
it's a journey
and
you
despite because when i when that
happened i thought i don't have another
script in me i don't have another
this was my next
great blue collar
script and i said what am i going to do
now
and um
you know i just had to take a step and
just have to live life and experience
new things and read you know i spent a
lot of time reading books and all this
stuff
and
slowly but surely i was able to
put it behind me and continue writing
and
you know now it's you know i'm over it
obviously it was a while ago um
but i think if you're if you're
if you're prepared to make a career out
of this and you're
really dead you're really dedicating
your life um
then you'll be you'll be okay and like
like anything else
like any other career you're gonna have
setbacks so
yeah sure do you think in some sense
maybe it was a blessing
that it happened so early on because you
did have such great success with steel
city and and you're still very young but
um
all this happened and it really gave you
a taste of like this is the business
yeah
i mean people always i hate this that
thing blessing in disguise
because um
i think had it worked out in my favor
things could have turned out differently
you know when i think my career
trajectory would have been much
different than it is now
um
but you can't you know you can't play
monday morning quarterback because
that's you know that's what everyone
does
uh was it a blessing i don't know i mean
that's it's what happened and i had to
adapt and and move on
i mean
um
but it definitely forced me to say you
know what
this is the way it goes you're not
always going to get your way you know
suck it up move on like you know like my
dad always used to say when i was a
young kid playing soccer you get knocked
down get back up keep going you know
that's just what it was
you